David Caldicott
While we're collecting information on the respiratory and cardiovascular
consequences of this level of pollution, we're probably going to start picking up
signal from other types of diseases, which we didn't anticipate.
And I suspect those sorts of chronic conditions may well be some of the ones
that we see some more information on.
I think the one that always gets missed in this space is the emotional,
the psychological impact of this. There's definitely a change in people who
are affected by it. There’s an anxiety,
there's a nervousness,
there's an anger. But there's a change in mood,
and I don't know whether that's because of the concerns about what this is doing to people's health.
You find in emergency medicine that one of the best things that you can do in
medicine is tell somebody what their disease is and where it's going to go.
And a lot of the time now, we're just like, you know:
'We can't do much about this at the moment.
We don't know much about it –
and as soon as we know something you'll hear about it'.
This is not reassuring for a patient.